all right so connor you're the very
first person out of the three of you
that i get to talk about one piece i
know right this is really strange
honestly this is gonna be a shock to
everyone because no one knows i've been
reading it i haven't said anything oh
this is like the first reveal basically
yeah i'm not gonna read any of the
comments of this as well because again i
don't want to be spoiled i'm still only
up to i think volume 15 of one piece
which is insane to think because if any
other if this is any other show this
should be a lot like i've read a lot but
in one piece it's nothing dude like
there's stories that are not even 15
volumes long so like it's completely
ruined my frame of reference for how
long manga is like normally every other
manga has like a i'm going to say
healthy uh duration whereas one piece it
just feels insane i've read so much it
takes so long to read 15 volumes
absolutely and i mean you can kind of i
don't even i think i have almost
everyone but like that's kind of is it
no this isn't all of that it's not all
of them it's like because i have all of
25 and it's probably
i have all of them and you could make a
chair out of it i'm not kidding you
genuinely could a throne i'm reading it
it looks like a throne in my living room
it's like it's so stupid it must take
away so much space also it does i've
realized that being a one-piece fan
requires you to have a lot of money
because you need to have real estate
you've got to have room to put it unlike
me
where do you put this where do you
where's all the bumpies
my room is 50 one piece of this oh my
god all right i was thinking let's start
it off with a couple of rapid fire
questions okay of god okay okay and then
we can kind of like go into a more
fluent conversation okay so number one
what's your favorite character at the
moment can i okay uh i'm gonna meme this
in the english translation it's zolo
solo zolo
and i i was reading it okay zolo is my
favorite zorro sorry actually [ __ ] i'm
meaning it too much zorro is my favorite
so far or sanji nice i i thought nami
was annoying but now i like nami too
okay nami's backstory kind of made me
think okay i made it fine all right fine
all right you got me but but zoro was
has been badass consistently and it's
been awesome like he's so funny
does no one like gusop yet is it it
tastes like a story
i figured they made him annoying but in
this currently i don't like him that
much but he has his moments i feel like
even for a character that is meant to be
annoying he's really fun and he has
moments of like getting over the
cowardice right which i like but uh yeah
what's up with the weird translations
dude it's yeah so i'm not sure if you're
aware there's basically an unofficial
translation of many things yeah and then
the official viz version yeah and this
version kind of had some interesting
translating uh choices
okay so one of the things i've one of
the things about these videos is that
i'm not i'm not telling anyone i'm
reading one piece obviously they're
going to find out now and i'm not going
to talk about it until i'm done yeah um
is that i'm going to talk about this and
probably have a bunch of weird stuff
that i picked up from the viz version
because i'm reading it all physically in
the english and it's viz so i'm gonna be
like yeah man i love zolo and i love i
love the the water guns in that one
scene it's like what's gonna happen i
don't
yeah the comments are gonna be probably
brutal once you put that video out but
it's not my fault it's the only thing i
can read i want to read it physically
and you should and you should it's good
why zolo wow solo i read apparently
because i googled it i was like i was
really confused it was one of those
things where like it was um
the mandela effect were you like your
swear you
heard it differently absolutely and i
did hear it differently because it was
sorrow i i googled it and apparently
it's because they were worried about
copyright with um zorro like the
swordsman really is that the actual
because obviously zorro is probably
named after zoro in some way yeah so
apparently they were quite worried about
that i don't know if that's true i don't
know if that's true that's what i read
oh that was interesting i just assumed
it was because of the japanese rule
which can be kind of like an it can be
working yeah oh interesting but maybe
that's why they felt safe doing the zolo
so like let's definitely pick the lame
name to be sure zolo sounds [ __ ] zorro
sounds cool i think zorro is my favorite
again i'm up to volume 15. so we just
started uh drum island
and probably my favorite scene so far uh
which kind of came out of nowhere was
the zorro versus the the swords guy who
turns up
basically kicks his ass then leaves but
it was so epic and it was so hype yeah
it came out of nowhere like
suddenly this guy just turns up and then
now zorro is like rock hard because he
wants to fight him and prove his worth
and this was so cool um that was
probably my favorite scene so really
yeah so if you're already taking my
questions away now oh okay okay [ __ ]
sorry i'm just talking about it okay
sorry sorry i'm just kidding it was
really cool though because like same
when i read first read it it was
as you said you kind of expect it to be
like something that comes at the end of
the story
and then it just happens right away
there was no reminder
no yeah it just turned out
all right okay that's kind of nice
though i feel like it's always cool to
like set up the character and then give
him like a big like drawback kind of
yeah kidding yeah now we know that like
i'm probably gonna get some payoff later
off i'm sure one piece fans are like
yeah yeah i know it's gonna happen it's
got to happen there's the whole point of
him existing
we'll find out this is why i'm just
going to read it so hard like not
spoiling you bro
i have to be so getting wrong like i'm
like maybe maybe not
who knows
all right um you already said like that
was your favorite fight and favorite
scene i guess so far maybe not my
favorite fight
what was your favorite fight then so far
oh
i think my favorite fight
there's been a lot of good ones i find
that
i
initially i was a bit kind of confused
with the fight because i couldn't really
figure out
if he was going for funny fights right
or if he was going for more serious
fights right yeah but now it's finally
filled like after about 10 vol 10
volumes yeah it finally felt like it got
to a point where okay we're going in the
more serious direction we're kind of
taking it a bit more seriously i like
that a lot and i think definitely uh the
restaurant fight was probably like the
sign where it felt like okay finally
because the character just gets gassed
like
like
it's just like it goes from like a clown
who's like really funny and wacky and
whoa we gotta tie him up we're not gonna
kill him to like i'm literally gonna
guess this guy and it's like older bro
what happened
i think we talked about this it's really
interesting because you kind of feel
like he's trying out so many different
things like is it a comedy is it like
really dark yeah yeah and it kind of
like it finds a bit more of a constant
but nonetheless throughout the story
like kind of switches things up
depending on the center yeah yeah
there'll be
moments of humor he loves doing the
things yeah looney tunes eyes popping
out yeah that always happens whenever
usab just says anything
it seems to be
uh but yeah i mean i the that's
definitely my favorite fight i think so
far i also really like the two giants oh
yeah those two were so fun and
especially you know they're they're kind
of uh closure to the ark they like hit
them [ __ ] right right it was so high
man and uh also the along fight was high
although i felt it kind of just ended
yeah it was pretty fast that's true i
thought that
in my in the video when i was recording
it i was like oh he's definitely gonna
come back because like he's not down
right he just got kicked and then and
then he just it just ends and then they
suddenly have a happy ending and they
all leave like what what especially in
early one piece i feel like the pacing
was a lot faster oh it's breakneck right
and yeah and like recently it's been
getting like the recent arc yeah that's
been going on um that's just been like
over 200 chapters at this point
so it's that time yeah it is it is it is
it literally is but it like it happens
more as you would expect it where like
the villains get back up more and more
and it's like kind of this more drawn
out fight but yeah olong literally got
like kicked once and then just didn't
get back up yeah and then that was it
and i was like wow okay i feel like in
that regard it was more about like the
emotional story behind it kind of yeah
it was definitely nominee's redemption
yeah that's what that whole lock was and
kind of helping you have a bit more
character development but you know right
now i think and i'm sure a lot of one
piece fans will maybe agree with me i
don't know if they will right now it
just feels like luffy is too op
that's the i think the main issue with
it is that it's almost boring to watch
luffy fight in a way because you just
know right now that he steals everyone
yeah uh whereas the other characters
even like zorro struggles sanji is just
busy off floating all the time
and then occasionally kicks the [ __ ] out
of people which i i [ __ ] with i like
that i like that sanji's fun sanji like
is like never there half the time but
turns up when there's a woman so i i
kind of that's pretty much how it goes
i kind of get it i don't actually
remember it's like the zorro getting
lost thing is that already a thing
he
yeah actually he has been lost a few
times all right or he's just not there
right that's kind of like the big meme
with him
yeah
he like gets lost everywhere you know
the weird thing about being an anime fan
is and not having read one piece is that
you pick up so much
weird one-piece like info and references
that mean nothing to you right and then
when you start reading one piece it's
like it's like being in like a dementia
state where you're just slowly
recovering yeah i'm like whoa i know
sorrow i know who chopper is i didn't
know what each offer is what it is
i i know what dropper is a character
that exists but i have no idea why and i
just saw chopper for the first time but
it doesn't look like chopper yeah so i'm
like
well they kind of change right because
they're like yeah yeah
that's so interesting that's kind of how
i feel with jojo honestly because i know
all the memes and all the reference but
i've never really watched it so i
actually like i think i told you like i
watched the the first season and then
kind of stopped
but while i was watching the first
season i was like i know that meme i
know the d or me
you know all the memes that's why you
gotta watch jojo but one piece doesn't
have many memes
yeah yeah yeah yeah i think like one
piece just is like generally you kind of
know the characters even if you haven't
read it but it's not as memeed if you as
you said if you haven't read the story
yeah i mean one piece is so prolific
that i knew all the charac the main
cast's names yeah without having ever
really consumed much right uh it's weird
because i did watch one piece in my
childhood the four kids versions
like but you could never like get the
episode in order so you kind of just
watch sporadic things so while i was
reading the arlung fight i had this
really weird memory of remembering this
kick just destroy this house right and
viewing it so i was like oh wow i have
seen this i just don't remember anything
at all you don't know until the scene
shows yeah yeah um i guess you get like
a lot of these moments where it kind of
bleeds in from like everyday life
obviously as you say like you talk about
anime a lot anyways and so you're kind
of aware with like certain scenes right
right yeah yeah yeah you know when you
watch videos about anime characters and
then right now if you'll get reference
and you'll be like what is a what is a
gun gun something right what the [ __ ] is
that like it sounds stupid it's actually
interesting because i always see like
people commenting like oh you guys
should read one piece and stuff you
never talk about one piece but i feel
like god and joey mention it fairly
often right yeah i think they haven't
spoke about it on the podcast at least
because i'm like please don't because i
want to read it so please don't spoil it
for me so they've been very kind but i'm
sure when we when i've caught up and
i've finished it i'm sure we're gonna be
talking about it a lot um there's just a
lot like one piece is
yeah it is it is i'm not even sure is
there like anything comparable probably
not like in that length i'm watching all
the simpsons i guess how long is how
long is all of jojo like there's like a
couple of
jojo i think um or i think churchill
actually has more chapters maybe than
one piece
jojo's been going on longer than one
piece he has like from the 80s 90s how
many jojo chapters but then also the
chapters have gotten longer as well it
has 131 volumes okay jojo is really long
but i think i feel like one piece might
get there
the thing with jojo is that also i think
even though it has more volumes i think
it has less uh like content oh yeah
i'm not i'm not sure i don't exactly
know i'm not that big of a manga guy but
jojo's really easy to consume because
you can read a part and stop right so oh
yeah it's it's a lot more episodic than
yeah a lot of people who would say that
jojo fans haven't read all the jokes
even i haven't read i haven't read all
of eight i've already read a bit of
eight and i don't know why i haven't
read eight yeah it's just kind of i want
to get around to it all right that's
fine but like i i think people would
argue i'm a big jojo fan and even i
haven't read eight right because it's
like you don't need to necessarily read
the next part right and a lot of people
are anime only and there's only yeah six
and a half well five and a half i guess
seasons season six halfway through yeah
yeah yeah uh i'm not gonna turn this
into a jojo video but you should you
should
after when i get into it we'll make a
video on it as well i will say with one
piece um so far there are definitely
been moments that are really boring in
it it was like what was like the
most
annoying or like boring moment you can
remember where you're kind of like
that's kind of like dragging on um
i was reading the arc on the one where
they were on the giant island with the
two warriors and like i
you know
this the whole uh what is it oh is it
baroque baroque baroque works yeah
baroque baroques assassins yeah like i
didn't mind some of them but like
assassin number three that fight was so
boring uh with the wax camera with the
wax candles i was i was like what dude
come on man this is lame it's like
they're stuck in wax
and it's like there's this really cool
moment where zoro's about to chop off
his legs to get out the wax i'm like
i mean it's wax like sure you can just
like cut it up or like i i mean it's
this is the and this is the dumbest way
to kill someone as a as a villain like
why are you just putting them in wax and
letting it slowly drip on them surely if
you have wax powers just envelop them in
wax and kill them like this this fight
was so boring and dumb and it felt so so
like stally right like it was like oh we
gotta have some kind of climb actually
the island yeah it was kind of like a
unnecessary fight maybe because like the
giants are kind of like the main thing
they were so cool and they could have
carried that part alone yeah yeah yeah
the whole assassins felt very like loony
toony as well where they're like
we're the bad guys yeah don't actually
do anything it's like oh we'll stop him
i would say there's a couple of like
more goofy villains really coming up
also but it's like it makes yeah it's
really hard for me not to think that
they're spoiling the thing that makes me
keep reading even when there's a few
boring moments here and there and
there's not many of them i will say that
so far it's been really entertaining uh
is that i'm i'm trusting one piece fans
it's as good as they say it is and i'm
going i'm going to keep going regardless
right because
why are people so obsessed with this
thing if it wasn't there right right i
think i like shonen so i'm sure i'm sure
i'll enjoy it right now like if you had
to give it a rating out of ten
right now seven out of ten seven out of
ten already yeah that's good it's that's
a relief oh it's solid yeah probably
gonna get better from here only because
there's been some arcs there's been some
fights like the restaurant yeah the
entire restaurant part was just such a
joy to read yeah like uh shinji's
backstory
sanji sanji [ __ ] my god
like sanji's backstory
yeah right oh my god what
sanji's backstory was amazing the every
character in that arc was just really
entertaining the villain although yeah
obviously we're going to win i didn't
really mind it it felt like it was going
to the stakes were there
everything felt good in that arc and
then zorro's part like that was such a
strong moment for me that was like a 10.
uh i will also say you're still stuck in
the period where we're like talking
early 2000s yeah if at all it's crazy so
it's like 2000 2001 2002
so obviously this like just the story
vibe itself is still in that period also
and the art style develops a lot more
in general i feel like you can kind of
tell with most stories that are this
long and they're like are successfully
that long you can also kind of tell the
author growing over time yeah yeah i i i
one thing i i really like about it so
far is that even though in some ways it
does feel a little dated like it feels
like a 2000 uh show when i'm reading it
i mean the art style early on especially
is like very 2000 absolutely i kind of
dig it though i really like the early
art style
it's pretty it's pretty awesome like it
feels it's really clean as well like a
lot of manga because you see that it's
you know it's kind of shaky in the start
yeah obviously not nowadays everyone's
like insane you have to otherwise you
don't like it but like back then it was
kind of like you know you kind of get
shaky and then like jojo's looks
interesting in the story and gets a lot
more interesting i'd say uh visually uh
but yeah it's it's really easy to read
like it looks amazing um i really like
that they've he keeps sprinkling in
information that i know will become
relevant later on but i'm talking like
way later oh yeah because there's just
been a bunch of things mentioned like
okay i i know this is going to be a
payoff thing because i've heard this
name a million times right they
mentioned blackbeard
for the first time and i know that
blackbeard is going to be a thing that
is hyped because people like years ago
were like oh my god did you watch the
blackbeard thing bro it was insane so
i've heard about that right right so i
know that's going to be a thing but it's
been hinted so early on and other things
have been hinted that i'm kind of you
know like the zorro fight with um i
forgot the guys yeah that that was
hinted on really early and i'm guessing
we're not going to pay off for a while
so there's a lot of things where i like
that they keep mentioning things
absolutely and if i remember it i'll be
rewarded later on dude there is legit
like stuff you're reading right now that
you just read yeah that like we kind of
know will have a payoff but that still
hasn't happened in the story so
dude
oh my god
his office has got to be like the crazy
person office where it's like [ __ ]
red line dude i think there is an image
how does he keep track of all this it's
ridiculous he has like folders and like
folders yeah i like
it's it's making me stressed thinking
about how he's gonna tie this all in
cohesively i think there's like this
image of him just like sitting in this
pile of like paper
looks
oh my god it's just like stuffed
with like research and so yeah
jesus christ i'm gonna put it up on
screen but it's
absolutely ridiculous how can you work
in that the thing is like he also takes
like so much inspiration from real life
events and locations so he has like all
these encyclopedias and whatever yeah no
i feel like he's really private as a guy
in general so there's not so much you
know about him a lot of a lot of
languages fair enough i feel like man
let me ask you this then okay okay if
you had to kill off one character you
could kill off a character you had the
you were able to because if they're
annoying you don't like them or whatever
like who would have i feel like the bait
answer is like usher right it's gonna be
like oh get rid of shop he sharks dude
but i feel like that's the point of
herself he's been to suck yeah like he's
meant to be like absolutely the loser
who i'm i'm hoping has some kind of you
know get his moment yeah which i'm
guessing he will because
i don't know honestly oh dude oh [ __ ]
dude oh no
so far like luffy's the most boring
is that is that allow you a lot to say
that i mean
it's like a crime in japan like no not
at all i think it's really fair it's
actually like i think luffy as a
character in general doesn't like
obviously throughout the story without
giving too much away there's like
moments where he develops as a character
yeah but he's more or less already a
pretty like as you can tell he's already
strong he's already like a kind of good
leader at the beginning yeah so he's
he's not changing as much and not hasn't
has as many flaws i would say as like
some of the most of the other characters
so it's hard to say i think especially
at that stage where you're at and you
know every other character we've had
some really deep backstory which is kind
of explained why they are and luffy we
just haven't really been told anything
he's just a weird kid right he's
basically gone from hunt to hunter right
now but but adult yeah right oh i knew
that he said he's like twelve so i don't
[ __ ] know that he's like yeah [ __ ]
child yeah like
gone is almost parallel to hunt hunter
in the first part but right so gone
changes as well and gone grows as a
character right though i'm guessing
would you would you agree that gone kind
of goes
like dark right like you kind of have
this negative character arc where he
goes like completely nuts at some point
but that's what makes gone awesome oh
yeah it's like
gone is like what happened if all those
things had actually happened to him
which is like they would make you
maybe make bad decisions which gone
probably makes some bad decisions
sometimes i mean he's kind of a parody
also like the classic shown in character
yeah because as you say like just like
luffy or like many other shonen heroes
he just like starts off it's just like
i'm strong and like always like ginky
and everything but then he goes downhill
at some point yeah you know like hunter
hunter is my favorite sharon
of all time it's really yeah it's it's
yeah there are similarities right now
between hunter absolutely especially the
starting like there's a hunter hunter
there's no tourists having like kind of
a kind of a slow start you know uh it
doesn't really kick off until a few
episodes in um but yeah one piece is
definitely a slow burner i think that's
one thing
for sure
it's hard as well because i'm also
reading all of it on camera and it's
like sometimes i want to read it but i
don't want to read it on camera right
it's like i just don't read it but fair
enough i'm trying to catch up i feel
like you have that pressure it's
probably a lot harder
yeah yeah but i'm trying to sit down and
at least read like when i do read it try
and read at least right three to six
months because you're kind of also
interacting with the camera and you want
to share your heart but yeah i'd say if
this video comes out i'm gonna ask you
please don't talk to me about anything
that happens after volume 15. yeah i'm
not going to read any of these comments
i don't want to i'll read it after i'll
read it after and i'll see what you guys
thought of
old me that didn't know about one piece
yeah please be kind also yeah nothing on
twitter and so on
[Laughter]
all right well
thanks thanks so much for sitting down
and giving this exclusive preview thanks
for
want to talk about it but watching can't
talk about it but i guess this is fine
yeah i'm not going to interact with this
you're going to put this out well you're
going to it's going to live on its own
yeah yeah i'm not going to touch
anything i'm just going to make the
thumbnail something very like
shits on one piece
one out of ten worse
i'm so confused because i people people
don't think i've read this yet right
right so people are gonna be like what
the [ __ ] was he getting bad clickbait
was gonna get connor what the [ __ ] was
he gonna talk about like luffy's like
hat i don't
okay yeah dude thank you thank you so
much for having me man this yeah
all right